servus skills und herzlich willkommen
aus die ihn am heutigen tage vielleicht
wieder abdrehen wir noch video mit wenig
und zwar eine snapshot rückwärts
challenge mit mehr oder weniger
bekannten liedern das passiert alles so
wir haben hinter der kamera im
profi-geschäft städte musik
angelegenheiten generiert und wer sucht
lieder für uns raus nimmt die wieder auf
lässt sie wieder deinen snapshot
rückwärtslaufen spielt sie uns vor und
wir müssen erraten welche hier sind und
dass sie ohne konsequenzen denn fest
aber ich gewinne dann darf ich wenig
sagen okay wie nie im nächsten video
möchte ich bitte das duo seine perücke
trägt ein paar hielt sich die bude leute
wollte er aber was mir einfällt da hab
ich ihnen auffallen wenn ich gewinne
werden auch noch eine version auf jeden
skandal gemacht mit meinem sondern
bestrafen in der anderen bestrafen uns
aber auch in sich hat ich hoffe das war
soweit alles klar unterlegen nahtlos
erst drop den ersten song
er redet man noch davon erkennt ein
radio im leben etwas gysi als alleinigen
christine jäger hat es aber dass nur
eine einzige lieblosigkeit ist ab 13 uhr
im radio gespielt aber dass ich mal
wieder dass der sound ist so kommt der
zweite chance
o
frank erkenntnis aber das glaube ich
nicht
ich bin fertig sein
ist es wirklich so nicht eingefallen was
ist das denn dass der sommerhit nicht
dass es 2016 ins gras ja okay okay
ja dieses mal weniger sondern nur auf
ihr kommt der günstigen moment um die
ecke mit einem grinsen präsentiert
richtig stolz sagt das käme ja was das
geräusche seien auf der gruppe
angeschlossen
danke
aber das ist reine kommt 32 stützen und
am 06
somit ist es gibt schon die eltern sind
die man kennen zum beispiel wichtig dass
zum beispiel andreas allerdings erkennen
dass
sido ich hab mich da wieder boden ist
mir das einmal vorstellen
doch sie habe man drei bestimmt bestimmt
lässt nämlich in die kuhle
major lazer die noch nicht eingefallen
das könnte jetzt sehr finale sein 53
das mache dann darf ich die kirmes
nämlich
377 ist kurz zu erklären sagen so elias
den sinn der kamera stand ist der
manager von dem typen der das lied
gemacht hat und wen ist der dicke mit
dem titel musik gemacht hat er wohnt ja
auch irgendwie direkt nebenan und wenig
kälte super gut kein alibi von dem und
euch mit eurem so minimal geschoben wo
man sparen ja aber wie
dann hab ich das ding gewonnen
fairer ausgleich nachdem drin wenn die
hersteller sind auf einmal gedanken was
im nächsten video maß bisschen was leute
fähig sein habe ich überlegt was richtig
schön knackiges heftiges für wenige was
in unserem nächsten machen was für die
nummer sechs auf jeden fall ab dass die
morgensonne musste jetzt muss an dem
morgen seien richtig also ich überlege
mir was gutes die wenigsten hier gibt es
ganze sehen
in diesem sinne wenig seiten verlinkt
danke auch an elias und bis zum nächsten
mal
3 und la serena